you and I both ends of History so let's
step back we've been talking about the
future we'll step back for a bit and
look at uh the 90s you created Mosaic
web browser the first widely used web
browser tell the story of that hot and
how did it evolve into Netscape
Navigator this is the early days so full
story so
um I remember born I was born a small a
small child um well actually yeah let's
go there like what what did you when
would you first fall in love with
computers oh so I hit the generational
jackpot and I hit the Gen X kind of
Point perfectly as it turns out so I was
born in 1971. so there's this great
website called WTF happened in 1971.com
which is basically 1971 when everything
started to go to hell and I was of
course born in 1971 so I like to think
that I had something to do with that did
you make it on the website I have I
don't think I made it on the website but
I you know somebody needs to add this is
this is where everything maybe I
contributed to some of the trends um
that they uh that they do every line on
that website goes like that right so
it's all it's all it's all picture
disaster but um but there was this
moment in time where because the you
know sort of the Apple you know the
Apple II hit in like 1978 and then the
IBM PC hit in 82 so I was like you know
11 when the PC came out
um and so I just kind of hit that
perfectly and then that was the first
moment in time when like regular people
could spend a few hundred dollars and
get a computer right so that I just like
that that resonated right out of the
gate
um and then the other part of the story
is you know I was using an apple too
that used a bunch of them but I was
using Apple too and of course it said in
the back of every Apple II and every Mac
it said you know designed in Cupertino
California and I was like Wow Cupertino
must be the like shiny City on the hill
like Wizard of Oz like the most amazing
like city of all time I can't wait to
see it and of course years later I came
out to Silicon Valley and went to
Cupertino and it's just a bunch of
office parks low rise apartment
buildings so the Aesthetics were a
little disappointing but you know it was
the the vector uh right of the of the
creation of a lot of this stuff um yeah
so so then basically but so part part of
my story is just the luck of having been
born at the right time and getting
exposed to PCS then the other part is um
the other part is when Al Gore says that
he created the internet he actually is
correct uh in in a really meaningful way
which is he sponsored a bill in 1985
that essentially created the modern
internet created book it's called the
NSF net at the time which is sort of the
first really fast internet backbone
um and uh you know that that build
dumped a ton of money into a bunch of
research universities to build out
basically the internet backbone and then
the super computer centers that were
clustered around
um the the internet and and one of those
universities was University of Illinois
where I went to school and so the other
stroke a lot that I had was I went to
Illinois basically right is that money
was just like getting dumped on campus
and so as a consequence we had on campus
and this is like you know 89 1991.
we had like you know we were right on
the internet back low and we had like T3
and 45 at the time T3 45 megabit
backbone connection which at the time
was you know wildly state of the art um
we had Curry super computers we had
thinking machines parallel super
computers we had silicon Graphics
workstations we had macintosh's we had
we had next cubes all over the place we
had like every possible kind of computer
you could imagine because all this money
just fell out of the sky
um you were living in the future yeah so
yeah quite literally it was yeah like
it's all it's all there it's all like we
had full Broadband Graphics like the
whole thing and it's actually funny
because they had this this is the first
time I kind of it sort of tickled the
back of my head that there might be a
big opportunity in here which is you
know they embraced it and so they put
like computers in all the dorms and they
wired up all the dorm rooms and they had
all these you know Labs everywhere and
everything and then they they gave every
undergrad a computer account and an
email address
um and the Assumption was that you would
use the internet for your four years of
college
um and then you would graduate and stop
using it
and that was that right yeah and you
were just retire your email address it
wouldn't be relevant anymore because
you'd go off in the workplace and they
don't use email you'd be back to using
fax machines or whatever did you have
that sense as well like what what you
said the the back of your head was
tickled like what was your what was
exciting to you about this possible
World well if this is so useful in this
container if this is so useful in this
contained environment that just as this
weird source of outside funding then if
if it were practical for everybody else
to have this and if it were cost
effective for everybody else to have
this wouldn't they want it and the
overwhelmingly the prevailing View at
the time was no they would not want it
this is esoteric weird nerd stuff right
that the computer science kids like but
like normal people are never going to do
email right or be on the internet right
um and so I was just like wow like this
this is actually like this is really
compelling stuff now the other part was
it was all really hard to use and in
practice you had to be a basically a CS
uh you know basically had a bscs
undergrad or equivalent to actually get
full use of the internet at that point
because it was all pretty esoteric stuff
so then that was the other part of the
idea which was okay we need to actually
make this easy to use
so what's involved in creating Mosaic
like in creating a graphical interface
to the internet yeah so it was a
combination of things so it was like
basically the web existed in an early
sort of described as prototype form uh
and by the way text only at that point
uh what did it look like what was the
web I mean well and the key figures like
what was the what was it like what paint
a picture it looked like Chad GPT
actually
um it was all text yeah
um and so you had a text-based web
browser yeah uh well actually the
original browser Tim berners Lee the
original the original browser both the
original browser and the server actually
ran on next next cubes so these were
this was you know the computer Steve
Jobs made during the interim period when
he during the decade long interim period
when he was not an apple you know he got
fired in 85 and then came back in 97 so
this was in that interim period where he
had this company called Next and they
made these literally these computers
called cubes and there's this famous
story they were beautiful but they were
12 inch by 12 inch by 12 inch cubes
computers and there's a famous story
about how they could have cost half as
much if it had been 12 by 12 by 13 but
it was like no like it has to be so they
were like six thousand dollar basically
academic workstations they had the first
CD-ROM drives
um yeah which were slow I mean it was
the computers were all but unusable um
they were so slow but they were
beautiful okay can we actually just to
take a tiny tangent there sure of course
the 12 a total by 12. uh they're just so
beautifully encapsulated Steve Jobs idea
of design can you just comment
on um what you find interesting about
Steve Jobs What uh about that view of
the world that dogmatic pursuit of
perfection in how he saw Perfection and
Design
yeah so I guess they say like look he
was a deep believer I think in a very
deep way I interpret it I don't know if
you ever really described it like this
but the way I'd interpret it is it's
like it's like this thing and it's
actually a thing in philosophy it's like
Aesthetics are not just appearances
Aesthetics go all the way to like deep
underlining underlying meaning right
it's like
I'm not a physicist one of the things
I've heard of physicists to say is one
of the things you start to get a sense
of when a theory might be correct is
when it's beautiful right like you know
they're right and so so so there's
something and if you feel the same thing
by the way in like human psychology
right you know when you're experiencing
awe right you know there's like a
there's like a there's a Simplicity to
it when you're having an interaction
with somebody there's an aesthetic it
would say calm it comes over you because
you're actually being fully honest and
trying to hide yourself right so they're
so so it's like this very deep sense of
Aesthetics and he would trust that
judgment that he had deep down like even
even if the engineering teams are saying
this is uh this is too difficult even if
the whatever the finance folks are
saying this is ridiculous the uh the
supply chain all that kind of stuff
stuff this makes this impossible number
two we can't do this kind of material
this has never been done before and so
on and so forth he just sticks by it
well I mean who makes the phone out of
aluminum right like
nobody else would have done that and now
of course if your phone is made out of
aluminum you know how crude what kind of
caveman would you have to be to have a
phone that's made out of plastic life
right so like so it's just this very
right and you know look it's it's
there's a thousand different ways to
look at this but one of the things is
just like look these things are Central
to your life like you're with your phone
more than you're with anything else like
it's in your it's going to be in your
hand I mean he you know you know this he
thought very deeply about what it meant
for something to be in your hand all day
long yeah well for example
here's an interesting design thing like
he he never wanted it it's my
understanding is he never wanted an
iPhone to have a screen larger than you
could reach with your thumb one-handed
and so he was actually opposed to the
idea of making the phones larger and I
don't know if you have this experience
today but let's say there are certain
moments in your day when you might be
like only have one hand available um and
you might want to be on your phone yeah
if you're trying to like
after texting you your thumb can't reach
the send button yeah I mean there's pros
and cons right and then there's like
folding phones which I would love to
know what he thought it thinks about
them uh but I mean is there something
you could also just Ling on because he's
one of the interesting
um figures in the history of Technology
what makes him
what makes him as successful as he was
what makes him as interesting as he was
uh what made him
um so productive and important in um in
in the development of Technology he had
an integrated worldview so the the the
the properly designed device that had
the correct functionality that had the
deepest understanding of the user that
was the most beautiful
right like it had to be all of those
things right it was he basically would
drive to as close to perfect as you
could possibly get right and I I you
know I suspect that he never quite you
know thought he ever got there because
most great creators are generally
dissatisfied you know you read accounts
later on and all they can all they can
see are the flaws in their creation but
like he got as close to perfect each
step of the way as he could possibly get
with the with the constraints of the of
the technology of his time
um and then you know look he was you
know sort of famous in the Apple model
it's like look they they will you know
this this headset that they just came
out with like it was like a decade long
project right it's like and they're just
gonna sit there and tune and tune and
polish and polish and tune and polish
and tune and polish until it is as
perfect as anybody could possibly make
anything yeah and then this goes to the
the way that people describe working
with him was which is you know there was
a terrifying aspect of working with him
which is you know he was you know he was
very tough
um but there was this thing that
everybody I've ever talked to work for
him says that they all say the following
which is he we did the best work of Our
Lives when we worked for him because he
set the bar incredibly high and then he
supported us with everything that he
could to let us actually do work of that
quality so a lot of people who were at
Apple spend the rest of their lives
trying to find another experience where
they feel like they're able to hit that
quality bar again even if it in
retrospect or during it felt like
suffering yeah exactly
what is that teach you about the Human
Condition huh so look so I say exactly
so the Silicon Valley I mean look he's
not you know George Patton in the you
know in the Army like you know there are
many examples in other fields you know
that are like this
um uh uh
specifically in Tech it's actually I
find it very interesting there's the
Apple Way which is Polish Polish Polish
and don't ship until it's perfect
because you can make it and then there's
the sort of the other approach which is
the sort of incremental hacker mentality
which basically says ship early and
often and iterate and one of the things
I find really interesting is I'm now 30
years into this like
they're a very successful companies on
both sides of that approach right um
like that is a fundamental
difference right in how to operate and
how to build and how to create that you
have world-class companies operating in
both ways
um and I don't think the question of
like which is the superior model is
anywhere close to being answered like
and my suspicion is the answer is do
both the answer is you actually want
both they lead to different outcomes
software tends to do better
um with the iterative approach
um the hardware tends to do better with
the uh you know sort of wait and make it
perfect approach but again you can find
examples in in in both directions uh so
the jury's still out on that one uh so
back to Mosaic so what uh
it was text based uh Tim berners-lee
what there was the web which was
text-based but there were no I mean
there was like three websites there was
like no content there were no users like
it wasn't like it wasn't like a
catalytic it had in there by the way it
was all because it was all text there
were no documents there were no images
there were no videos there were no right
so so it was it was and then if in the
beginning if you had to be on a next
cube right you need a hat index Cube
both to publish and to consume so so
there were six thousand bucks you said
there were limitations like yeah six
thousand dollar PC they did not they did
not sell very many but then there was
also there was also FTP and there was
Usenet right and there was you know a
dozen other basically there's waste
which was an early search thing there
was gopher which was an early menu-based
information retrieval system there were
like a dozen different sort of scattered
ways that people would get to
information on on the internet and so
the Mosaic idea was basically bring
those all together make the whole thing
graphical make it easy to use make it
basically bulletproof so that anybody
can do it and then again just on the
luck side it so happened that this was
right at the moment when Graphics when
the GUI sort of actually took off and
we're now also used to the GUI that we
think it's been around forever but it
didn't really you know the the Macintosh
brought it out in 85 but they actually
didn't sell very many Max in the 80s it
was not that successful of a product
um it really was when you needed Windows
3.0 on PCS and that hit in about 92.
um and so when we did mosaican 92 93 so
that sort of it was like right at the
moment when you could imagine actually
having a graphical user interface to
right at all much less one to the
internet how uh how old did Windows 3
sell so it was that the really big that
was the Big Bang the big operating
graphical operating system well this is
the classic okay this Microsoft was
operating on the other so Steve Steve
Apple was running on the Polish until
it's perfect Microsoft famously ran on
the other model which is ship and
iterate and so in the Old Line in those
days was Microsoft race version three of
every Microsoft product that's the
that's the good one right so there there
are you can you can find online Windows
One windows two nobody used them yeah
actually the original Windows the in the
original Microsoft Windows the windows
were not overlapping
um and so you have these very small very
low resolution screens and then you had
literally um Windows it just didn't work
it wasn't ready yet well in Windows 95 I
think was a pretty big leap also that
was a big leap too yeah so that was like
bang bang
um and then of course Steve and then and
then you know in the fullness of time
Steve came back then the Mac star took
off again the third bang and then the
iPhone was the fourth bang such exciting
time and then we were afternoon Off to
the Races because nobody could have
known
what would be created from that well
Windows 3.1 or 3.0 Windows 3.0 to the
iPhone was only 15 years
right like it that ramp was in
retrospect at the time it felt like it
took forever but that in history in
historical terms like that was a very
fast ramp from even a graphical computer
at all on your desk to the iPhone that
was 15 years so did you have a sense of
what the internet will be as you look
into the window of Mosaic like
what you're like there's just a few web
pages for now so the thing I had early
on was I was keeping at the time what
this disputes over what was the first
blog but I had one of them that at least
is a is a is a is it possible um at
least a runner-up in the competition um
and it was what was called the what's
new page
um uh and it was it was it was hardwired
a distribution uh unfair Advantage I've
wired put it right in the browser I put
it in the browser and then I put my
resume in the browser which also it was
hilarious but um
I would I was getting the not many
people get to get to do that so oh no
the uh
good good call yeah and early days yes
it's so interesting I'm looking for my
uh about about oh it's looking at your
job
um so um wow so the West new page I
would literally get up every morning and
I would every afternoon
um and I would basically if you wanted
to launch a website you would email me
um and I would list it on the what's new
page and that was how people discovered
the new websites as they were coming out
and I remember because it was like one
it literally went from it was like one
every couple days to like one every day
until like two every day
so you're doing it so that that blog was
kind of doing the directory thing so
like what was the home page uh so the
homepage was just basically trying to
explain even what this thing is that
you're looking at right basic basically
basic instructions
um but then there was a button there's a
button that said what's new and what
most people did was they went to
previous reasons went and what's new but
like it was so it was so mind-blowing at
that point just the basic idea and it
was this was like you know this is
basically the internet but people could
see it for the first time the basic idea
was look you know some you know it's
like literally it's like an Indian
restaurant in like Bristol England has
like put their menu on the web and
people were like wow whoa because like
that's the first restaurant menu on the
web yeah and I don't have to be in
Bristol and I don't know if I'm ever
gonna go to Bristol and I don't even
like Indian food and like wow right um
and it was like that uh the first web uh
the first streaming video thing was a uh
it was another England some expert or
something
um some guy uh put uh his coffee pot up
as the first uh streaming uh video thing
and he put it on the web because he
literally the coffee pot down the hall
yeah and he wanted to see when he needed
to go uh refill it um but there were you
know there was a point when there were
thousands of people like watching that
coffee pot
because it was the first thing you could
watch
but right isn't uh were you able to kind
of infer
you know of that Indian restaurant could
go online then you're like okay they all
will yeah exactly so you felt that yeah
yeah now you know look it's still a
stretch right it's still a stretch
because it's just like okay it's you
know you're still in this Zone which is
like okay is this a nerd thing is this a
real person thing yeah
um by the way we you know there was a
wall a skepticism from the media like
they just like everybody was just like
yeah this is the current this is just
like dumb this is not you know this is
not for regular people at that time
um and so you had to think through that
and then look it was still yeah it was
still hard to get on the internet at
that point right so you could get kind
of this weird bastardized version if you
were on AOL which wasn't really real or
you had to go like learn what an ISP was
um you know in those days PCS actually
didn't have TCP drivers come
pre-installed so you had to learn what a
TCP driver was you had to buy a modem
you had to install driver software
um I have a comedy routine I do so it's
like 20 minutes long describing all the
steps required to actually get on the
internet
um and so you had to you had to look
through these practical yeah well then
and then uh and then speed performance
in 14 form modems right like it was like
watching you know glue dry
um like and so you had to you had they
were basically a sequence of bets that
we made where you basically needed to
look through that current state of
affairs and say actually there's going
to be so much demand for that once
people figure this out there's gonna be
so much demand for it that all of these
practical problems are going to get
fixed yes some people say that the
anticipation makes the
the destination that much more exciting
do you remember Progressive jpegs yeah
do I do I so forget for kids in the
audience right for kids you used to have
to watch an image load like a line at a
time but it turns out there was this
thing with jpegs where you could you
could load basically every fourth you
could load like every fourth uh line and
then and then you could sweep back
through again and so you could like
render a fuzzy version image up front
and then it would like resolve into the
detailed one and that was like a big UI
breakthrough because it gave you
something to watch
yeah and uh you know there's
applications in various domains for that
uh
it was a big fight if there was a big
fight early on about whether there
should be images on the web
um for that reason for like
sexualization no not not explicitly that
did come up but it wasn't even that it
was more just like all the serious the
argument went the purists basically said
all the serious information in the world
is text if you introduce images you you
basically going to bring in all the
trivial stuff you're going to bring in
magazines and you know all this crazy
y'all just you know stuff that you know
people you know it's going to distract
from that it's gonna go take take away
from being serious being frivolous well
was there any uh Doomer type arguments
about uh the internet destroying all of
human civilization or destroying some
fundamental fabric of human civilization
yeah so if those days it was all around
crime and terrorism uh so those
arguments happened um you know but there
was no sense yet of the internet having
like an effect on politics or because
that was that was way too too far off
but um there was an enormous panic at
the time around cyber crime there was
like enormous Panic that like your
credit card number would get stolen and
you'd use life savings to be drained and
then you know criminals were gonna there
was oh um when we started one of the
things we did one of the the Netscape
browser was the first widely used piece
of consumer software that had strong
encryption built in it made it available
to Ordinary People and at that time
strong encryption was actually illegal
to export out of the U.S so we could
field that product in the US we could
not export it because it was it was
classified as ammunition
um so the Netscape browser was on a
restricted list along with the Tomahawk
missile as being something that could
not be exported so we had to make a
second version with deliberately weak
encryption to sell overseas with a big
logo on the box saying do not trust this
which it turns out makes it hard to sell
software uh when it's got a big logo
that says don't trust it
um and then we had to spend five years
fighting the US government to get them
to basically stop trying to do this but
because the fear the fear was terrorists
are going to use encryption right to
like plot you know all these all these
all these things
um and then you know we responded with
well actually we need encryption to be
able to secure systems so the terrorists
and the criminals can't get into them so
that was anyway that was the night that
was the 1990s fight